azerbaijan's economy is fueled by its
gas and oil production
the country now has its eyes set on
europe's energy crisis
it says it has the supply to ease
europe's growing demand
we are already a substantial if not a
very serious
player
in the turkish market in the georgian
market in the europe markets of greece
uh italy and bulgaria
but we have huge interest from the side
of the others
from the eastern european countries from
the bolton countries from the central
european countries much of its natural
gas supply is exported through what's
called the southern gas corridor which
runs from the caspian sea through parts
of georgia turkey and then to europe
azerbaijan's production is small
compared to big players in the energy
game but with this gas corridor it is
ready to carry other resources like gas
from turkmenistan to the eu going after
a bigger piece of the market
by increasing its energy production
azerbaijan could bring in more
investments and gain political leverage
in its region but this could also
threaten its relationship with russia a
major ally and one of the world's
biggest energy suppliers
azerbaijan says it is not competing with
moscow but some analysts say there could
be geopolitical complications
the existing monopolistic supplier also
as i said in the beginning uh uses
its supplies of energy to europe for
geopolitical reasons for geopolitical
influence we see that right now
right now when russia has uh not
delivered gas to gas storage facilities
in europe throughout the summer
and has decided not to do what it
normally does which is increase supplies
to europe uh when you're asked for more
because gazprom and russia are trying to
pressure the european union
their concerns russia's dispute with
ukraine and other european partners
could destabilize energy supply
russia provides about 45 percent of the
european union's natural gas needs but
demand is growing and it appears russia
can't or won't keep up
if you look at what is happening in
terms of energy
security and some fluctuations of energy
uh
provision of energy sources energy
supply to some countries in europe for
example
and azerbaijan being able to deliver its
natural gas to europe enables these
countries
these consumers to access to alternative
source of energy
european leaders fear the energy crisis
may get worse before it gets better
azerbaijan hopes it will turn into an
opportunity that will secure its role in
the market
baku azerbaijan